sin confuso a la situación de los
corredores humanitarios en ucrania
corredores humanitarios que deberían
permitir la huida de civiles de las
zonas donde se están llevando a cabo los
combates más intensos personas que como
los 300.000 que siguen el mariupol en el
tercer día de intento de evacuación
están a la espera de poder subirse en
ocho camiones y 30 autobuses que
deberían entregar también ayuda
humanitaria y permitir la evacuación
también de otras ciudades en la ciudad
de sap orilla que como hemos dicho en
los pasados días alberga una importante
central nuclear se trata de un contexto
que ocurre en un momento en el que
siguen los enfrentamientos en el país lo
demuestran las cifras que difundió el
gobierno ucraniano la cifra de muertos
durante la noche en la ciudad de sume
una de las ciudades que están siendo más
bombardeadas en las últimas horas han
fallecido allí unas 21 personas entre
las cuales lamentablemente también hay
niños esto demuestra que la guerra sigue
en curso en ucrania que las esperanzas
de paz lamentablemente todavía no se han
concretado